I've been hooked on Instagram lately.
I don't particularly stand out at work
or in my private life...
but when I post cute pictures,
I get validation from lots of people.
1 LIKE
People whose faces I don't even know
are cheering me on
with their "likes" from afar.
LIKES
It's nothing special.
This is 1,800 yen?
You got 54 "likes," huh?
Well, it's an improvement.
Thank you, coach!
I owe it all to your helpful pointers!
-You're not quite there yet.
-What?
You're not putting any thought
into your shots.
Take this pic, for example.
Some old guy's head
is totally in the frame.
Argh!
In this case...
first, you should change the angle
to cut him out.
Use the light from the window
as a half-backlight.
Make the subject pop
by blurring the background,
and add a little finishing touch.
Wow! It looks even more mouth-watering!
With that, your "likes" will double.
Coach, you're amazing!
Now, let's work on your selfies.
What the heck is this?
It's absolutely terrible!
-I forgot...
-Huh?
All this talk of Christmas
has reminded me that I found
a new restaurant online yesterday!
Their Christmas menu
is available for a limited time only.
It's so cute
and I was planning to go today.
Oh, I see.
Where is this place?
In Kamakura.
Kamakura?
Well, I'm off now!
You're going there now?
It begins as a hobby, but soon,
posting pics becomes an obligation.
Before you know it,
she'll be going out of her way
to a café in a different prefecture,
just to post a single pic.
It's begun.
She's stuck in the bottomless pit
that is Instagram!
We're gonna get a complaint
from Instagram.
3 LIKES
Retsuko, do you have
any plans for Christmas Eve?
What?
No...
I haven't made any plans yet.
How can you be so calm?
Christmas Eve is less than a week away!
Yeah...
A special date!
A party with your closest friends!
No other event is more important
for Instagram girls than Christmas Eve.
Can't I just spend time at home
with my family?
No.
Don't you get it? Your private life
is no longer yours alone.
It belongs to everyone!
Who would be interested
in a boring, conventional Christmas?
Who would give that "likes"?
Bigger! Grander! Pull out all the stops.
Broadcast your glamorous lifestyle
to the world and share your happiness!
That's our duty as Instagram girls.
Well, good luck!
I'll...
I'll do my best.
5,359 LIKES
DINNER WITH BAE TONIGHT
Why is it just me?
Merry Christmas!
I can still do it! Battling alone!
If I give in now, it's seriously over
Social media! Social media!
It's where I document my Christmas Eve
Only the number of "likes" I receive
Makes me feel alive
RETSU